now where the fight your first UFC
experience dude I saw you back there
yelling get in there you yeah you know I
singled you out cuz I saw [ __ ]
Santino's ready Oh how's it go clear
steel Santino is just I mean you could
see him from a million miles away he's
kind of like one of those road flares
that people put out when there's an
accident just [ __ ] bright red yeah
it's just like yeah this is spray of
violent red - did you have fun at the
fight skate it was crazy man bro I
couldn't well a couple times I called
the police I was like your kid yeah I
was like just two men that will not stop
fighting hey you know I was like it yeah
during the one I was like there's a
black guy that keeps hitting this
Mexican guy okay stop Wilmot stop stop
kick him in the leg ya won't do anything
about it
I said salt there's one guy that keeps
stopping up the cop went sir wary I'm at
a UFC fair I miss my State Farm arena
brother okay and you guys should be down
here there's a couple of you buddies
around here just milling around about to
fire a gun in one of these guys was it
it was crazy more violent or less flat
knees would like going in what'd you
think you're gonna see because I told
you I might now listen watch on TV is
one thing seeing it in person especially
we have broken seats it's it's intense
Oh
first of all you feel like you're in the
back of her like Rogen is driving you
somewhere you're in the back in the year
in the back of his car you feel like
you're his kids you're like just six
antisocial studios ride like Rogan
experience do I cheer do I not am I
being good you asked that for popcorn
what do I do
you know and Rogen's up there eating
rare meat he's eating [ __ ] cheetah
limbs and you know whatever else
drinking the blood you know you get a
little somebody bringing a tray of blood
from [ __ ] to bed between rounds TRT
yeah so how much he works during the
fight is pretty crazy like I couldn't
even for five hours I couldn't even
communicate had one moment of
communication non-stop yeah cuz he like
does the thing and then runs into the
ring to do the interview runs out he's
the best ever do it yeah I mean he just
it just doesn't stop
he's real seamless oh did you meet DC no
he's from Louisiana
I thought by the time I got to maybe
meet him it was the end of the night and
I just felt like he's probably pretty
tired like to see though he's a great
deal oh man I'm a huge fan you were
crunk about Poirier
oh poor a [ __ ] what is happening
right why steel acting like you I was
head your little flat tits all perked up
you hiked your shorts oh my god
it's the dardan it's the daughter what
are you watching you guys watch your
Instagram video
I think yeah so dusting like this
yeah cool man he'd even know you he's
like all right yeah thanks handsome lady
I did I did feel like I did there was a
point where I just that felt like a lot
lizard
I mean cuz I am now I use the terms you
can't use it this episode okay Brittany
could be anything like yeah this lady
made me a sandwich like he's like all
these long lizards it blew my mind man
it blew my mind how I woke up actually
two nights ago I woke up and watched a
fight again on YouTube and right yeah
and it was nothing compared to how
insane it was in person it gave me a
different respect for four fighters like
just the fact that it's like just to
come out round after round like
sometimes the round would be ending and
I'm like oh my god I got three more yeah
and you could see they were kind of like
elated the round was any because they
were tired but then I'm like dude you
just minute you have to come right back
five minutes then guys whoopin your ass
right back the principal is not going to
come out and stop some say it's the
worst job in the world depends you talk
to yeah um but yeah I was excited for
dustman I think like great story yeah it
was a great story and and just to see
max Holloway I mean his confidence dude
he kept finding both of them just kept
fighting they could have fought all
night I bet that's crazy for your first
fight you got those two fights as a main
event co-main event you're lucky really
yes super lucky yeah sometimes gonna be
a bummer but yummy well Brandon Davis
came out right in the beginning the
first fight on the prelims and those
guys beat the [ __ ] out of each other I
felt like they were just like it's
almost spouse it'll be like I couldn't
tell who the woman was but there was a
lot of spousal news I'm not going on of
do domestic violence below that
everywhere some guy needed a blood
transfusion he was standing above the
ring with his mouth open
and he [ __ ] caught a couple pints and
then he went out those typos you know he
looked great when he left
um but yeah that fight was and that was
the first one that was you know is there
wasn't even that many people there at
that point if he would come late go to
fight in Vegas people don't show up to
the main event it's so disrespectful
like watch a fight in Vegas usually
you'll see like behind Rogan empty empty
empty then like by the third card on the
main card you know by the third fight
people start filling in I'm like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah they just wait for
that main event did I keep Hollywood
[ __ ] yeah it was hot like Shaq came at
about with about maybe three fights left
damn Shaquille he's such a hassle yeah
we come to watch three fights I know you
like to shock us in front of you bro
oh he's sat in front of somebody down in
Dallas Page oh that makes sense
yeah but Dallas is that yoga so he just
can't Dallas does that yoga but you also
can't see anyways yes eyes are a little
like you know those dogs with cataract
that's what Diamond Dallas Page so he
just has no idea he thought fight was
going on staring at Shaq's [ __ ] neck
I think it's about Shaq's neck was far
as I'd am it's only black guys on this
car you know it's all black car no it's
cool that make sense
it's like pray per view he's just pray
and he can see anything dude I had
Steven Seagal sin from two girls in he's
big dude he's a chef yeah we're some
[ __ ] clothes and I was with a bunch
of USC fighters and someone say so Kate
kept standing out the chin and we
couldn't see and this was in Toronto so
I'm gonna say something shop and like I
want to say some you just say something
like plus you mean I go sit down
like this he turned around I was like I
was so scared
hey Steven uh we're just gonna try to
enjoy the final of it or do you mind
just trying to sit down sighs I didn't
want to get a death touch to the neck
bro I've never seen in his videos in
Russia just [ __ ] chopping dudes I
didn't want that dude he beat up 19 guys
on a shady cruise ship and Russia like
40 years old dude he's still posting
shitty city and yet the yellow glasses
on the squinty little eyes man bun uh
yeah double chin Oh
he's getting big dude it looks like he
just recently bought emeril lagasse it
looks like he can maybe meet him real
agassi we take the ladle I just say man
we're all scared of him yeah that's good
but dude definitely different gave me
like a little bit of a different respect
fee I can't believe money dude oh yeah
you do I mean I woulda been a grand yeah
and that was no district but disrespect
against it does it was fun for us sure
wasn't yeah guy sure they try to give
money to cut your hair they didn't
believe in you Dustin okay yeah [ __ ]
does this on the show tomorrow your bet
$1,000 that you didn't believe me no I
believe in max Holloway bro it's look
and I believe in max Holloway and no you
don't you don't believe max Holloway
that's why you took the bet you son of a
[ __ ]
max hope you're watching it is what it
is brother $40 40 50 we did make it 50
and I put 300 on Poirier online no I
don't believe that sports betting got AG
but dude it definitely I can't believe
you used to do that you you either bro
what were you doing out there I had no
other idea I don't know I'll just run it
around like a chicken my head cut off
and just [ __ ] huge why my dad call
the cops
that's why get out in the [ __ ] like you
all right and then I never got paid well
yeah that's oh that was another thing
that I felt man bro no joke I don't get
like bad vibes around that many people
but Dana White I mean I'm Gravas
grateful to be it as a van I know it's
their business but somebody should start
a different company or something and I
mean it's just the bad juju dude it's
bad have you ever been around a promoter
just feels dirt it felt dirty you know
it smells like when you're around like a
drug dealer a little bit yeah you're
just like mmm I just feel it's like a
darkness I don't care if the drug dealer
have you know coke and a little bit of
aspirin but if he only got coke and he's
not trying to help at all either and
he's just getting you hooked if you
don't have that Tylenol PM yeah it just
seemed like um I just didn't trust him
you know that was a thing I don't know I
mean maybe I'll shoot oh yeah should you
so I should be a fighter yeah that's a
thing he controlled he you know what he
seemed like to me was a slave owner and
a weird that's exactly what it is
it's executives and nondescript note and
I'm no color to slaves you know or
anything like that but just that the
worldwide slave trader and I feel like
there's a better way it felt to me like
business-wise which I look I don't know
[ __ ] anything I got beat up by Brad
Castleman when I was in [ __ ] 6th
grade and then this other guy who ended
up being a cop who I think ended up
beating some people you know it hit me a
couple times in math class or something
still counts though you know yeah yeah
I'm over - but dude I did fall off a
[ __ ] roof one time when I was
painting and land on a guy and he got
knocked out that counts so that's - I'm
one called a DDT a country DDT Oh
brownie got paint in his [ __ ] eyes
but yeah what's on that he was never the
same after that but I say he was never
the same before the hey what's up now
bro yeah it's his weird business dude
yeah it just felt a dirty business but
that's what like but in the ring there's
nothing you know I don't know I don't
know how you beat let me ask you this
there and then this is too serious for
this type of podcast when you watch it
what Dustin went through and what max
Holloway went through how much do you
think they should have made that night
when you watched what style bender and
Kelvin gas and went through oh my god
Kelvin Gastelum that guy fought
basically the usain bolt of [ __ ] UFC
in board shorts is unfortunate
he's a small Mexican dude dude ace they
should have let him be on a horseback or
something up there again at least give
him a chainsaw yeah give him a boat
paddle or something like give him some
weapons yeah see it's unfair they let
that guide you and bro he was fearless
how tough is he under if to me he was
the toughest guy the knight by far
correct
the toppings toughest well I dude
between mags II dusted I got a style
bender oh [ __ ] American there's got lit
the [ __ ] up again Scalia Roundtree's
just like I'm just gonna keep going yeah
Eric haters like bro I tapped out for
him I even hit his mom up on my
Instagram I was like hey
or ideas like hey if you have a towel
just throw it from wherever you're at
mom see if it works God it wasn't i
watch it different and we'll move on
after I think those guys should get a
half-million [ __ ] those guys should
become safer hmm but here's the thing if
you think a million people bought in
eighty bucks a pop if a million people
didn't buy a million people didn't so
maybe if 300,000 people paid to watch
and eighty bucks a pop then you're
looking at still that's twenty twenty
two million dollars so twenty two
million dollars then think of the ESPN
money that ESPN gives the UFC to ear
that pay-per-view right think of all the
sponsors so you know how the Octagon
looks like a NASCAR yeah the fighters
don't see any of that money right I
think of the Reebok gear that they win
if I don't see any of that money Wow so
does the US like other coaches do they
pay for the girls coaches no oh you're
kidding no the paint you get one coach
to fly to fly you and one coach to the
event Oh what can you do men entertain
man it hurts right yeah just yeah it
just feels wrong but it doesn't take
away from what those guys do out there
it doesn't take away from the fact that
they go out there and are champions but
yeah at that if that's the rates man
they should get a million bucks a pop
easy you know but yeah congratulations
to all the fighters man it made me it
gave me a whole different respect you
know I went to I actually went to
workout this morning there was a couple
times where I wanted to give up today
and I was like I'm gonna keep just
thought of even just any of those guys
out there I was like damn even Boston
salmon dude named after a [ __ ] great
name yeah
named after a [ __ ] great name I was
[ __ ] item a menu item like Boston
Market Boston salmon yeah think about
that dude just naming somebody off of a
[ __ ] menu item and he were Grove
cauliflower who's next
he worked out oh yeah yeah
and if yeah I I just blew my mind man it
was very impressive sport but seeing it
there live it's way more intense and way
more violent my dad used to hold his
breath will not fight really yeah can
hold his breath for about 15 minutes is
your dad a shark he's a whale oh is he
all right let's do this well underwater
father I can see it's still a mammal man
oh yeah man much more respect to you bro
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching